el remoto origen de la quinua que posee
muchas virtudes nutricionales está en
las riberas del lago titicaca desde hace
siglos agricultores como los aymaras
ismael cruz y margarita zárate cultivan
este alimento rico en proteínas
aminoácidos vitaminas y minerales
aquí no es más alimento para nuestro
cuerpo para nuestro cuerpo a que sea
fuerte para que no nos hagas de las
enfermedades
ismael y margarita cultivan la quinua
para su consumo pero no han logrado
desarrollar sus plantaciones por falta
de tierras en cambio los productores de
las regiones sureñas de potosí y oruro
tienen una planta industrial para
procesar y exportar la variedad de
quinoa real orgánica la que consideran
la más nutritiva del mundo
este producto es exportado a europa con
los sellos respectivos para la
producción orgánica también a eeuu sin
embargo los precios se han desplomado
porque el número de países productores
de quinoa ha pasado de 20 a más de 100
aunque la exportación de quinoa
representa muy poco porcentaje de las
ventas de bolivia y no parece afectar su
economía
70.000 campesinos si están sufriendo por
no recuperar sus costos de producción el
gobierno les ha ofrecido apoyo para
ingresar a nuevos mercados
pueden a ver si el país esté produciendo
la quinoa yubá no vamos a alcanzar a la
demanda internacional
ahora hay que trabajar en eso para que
nosotros
y tengamos un
un valor adicional por
el país de origen
mientras tanto y como hace siglos los
indígenas de las riberas del lago
titicaca siguen produciendo para sí
mismos el alimento más poderoso de los
andes' ajenos a los vaivenes del mercado
internacional